in
august of 2000
i was heading out of my front door
to go to a friend's wedding in houston
and literally was just opening the door
dragging my suitcase
out and my phone rang it was my mom
and she said something's happened
something's happened
i didn't know what but i dropped my case
and ran downstairs to catch a taxi
what little information i had i knew
that my sister who's to be married
in two weeks something had happened to
her fiance
but i didn't know what
i couldn't get a taxi because it was
rush hour
and everyone was fighting in new york
city to get a taxi and so i begged
a person to let me share with them and
they did
and i'm so glad i was able to get there
because by the time i got to the
hospital i was the only person
i was the only person with my sister
when she found out
that her fiance had died
they were on a train on a subway
heading downtown to get their marriage
license
and he wasn't feeling well he felt faint
and so as they pulled into the stop that
they needed to get out of
he stepped between the cars to get air
we don't fully know what happened
whether he fainted
or had a heart attack but he fell
and he touched the third rail the
official cause of death was
electrocution
my sister was holding onto his pant leg
when it happened
that happened 20 years ago in august
and my sister said to me can we do a
podcast about it
and so that's what we're doing
she's sitting right across from me and i
don't think i've ever talked about this
with her
in 20 years since it happened we make
references to it
but we've never talked about it
so my first question for you is why did
you want to do this
first of all i've never even heard what
happened that morning from your
perspective
let me take a step back 20 years is a
long time
and i've always
kept this very close to my heart i felt
this was my story my grief my heart
and i i don't talk about it very often
because it's difficult it's mine and
yet when i experienced it
i was 25 years old and i felt really
alone
when it happened because it wasn't like
this happens every day that i had people
to talk to
and who understood me
and two weeks after peter died
i received a phone call from a friend
saying
there's a friend of a friend this woman
julie is trying to reach you
and she had a similar situation
and she wants to talk to you she read it
in the newspaper it was all over the
news
in new york city when this happened and
reached out to me
and i felt a real sense of relief when i
got that phone call because i was like
wow there's actually somebody that
kind of understands what i'm going
through and
this woman julie became my beacon of
hope and i remember we
talked once in a while and she had
suffered something
similar her fiance had died in a tragic
accident seven years ago
and for me it wasn't necessarily that
she understood
what i went through i mean we had the
shared empathy and we had the shared
understanding but for me more than that
she was seven years ahead of me
she was my hope she would had remarried
she had kids and i was like oh my god
like
that could be me like i can get there
and
even though i hardly talked to her
hardly saw her we saw we had coffee once
in a while
i kept her in the back of my head all
the time because she made me get up
every morning
because i knew i i could my life could
go on
and that's the reason i wanted to do
this interview because every day
i look at the news unfortunately and see
the hundreds of thousands of people
who are dying from coven 19 and from
other tragic circumstances
and i can't stop thinking about all the
people that are
suffering right now the families that
are suffering the spouses the
children and if i can be a beacon of
hope for one person
through this interview like that would
fulfill me
and i've always
wondered how i can use my experience my
story
to help one other person and i hope i
can be that beacon of hope because
yes 20 years is a long time it's taken
me a long time
but everyone out there
can move forward
i remember i was with you when the
doctors came out and gave us the news
that he didn't make it
and sometime later i don't have any
recollection of how long
mommy and daddy then showed up
and we moved around a lot as kids and so
we really only had each other
the four of us and so to have the four
of us there
it was a big deal and i remember we went
back to mommy and daddy's house
and we had a wedding in two weeks and so
you were being consoled and i remember
my job was
to call family and say that there wasn't
going to be a wedding
and i remember calling grandma first
but the thing that i found amazing about
that experience was
you know we're a pretty tight family
already but we became an
unbelievably tight family
and this is the optimist to me i
remember very quickly
seeing the silver lining in this cloud
after we had gotten through the shock
what went through my mind was something
could have happened to you
he was touching the third rail and you
were holding on to him you could have
been electrocuted and you weren't
i know that you stayed at mommy and
daddy's house
for a couple months and then
you had an apartment with peter and i
remember eventually you moved back
home unfortunately i lived just up the
street
and anytime you wanted me to i would
come and sleep on your couch i remember
no you you moved in with me did i i
moved to that you slept on my couch for
a long time
oh okay i slept on your couch oh i do
remember that's right i slept on your
couch
the night before i'd go get my clothes
for work the next day and i'd come to
you you're right i slept on the couch
for a long time
i forgot about that the thing that
stands out for me
was the relationship i had with you and
how you
manage this and the relationship you had
with our parents how you managed it was
very different like they were there to
console you and
and i was a little more of a voice of
reality i remember telling you that
the first time peter's birthday came up
but the first time this happened i would
always tell you it's just the first time
it's gonna hurt the most the first time
but it'll be easier the second time and
all of these things will happen more
than once
i remember that yeah i remember
you and i talking about that and i had
prepared myself that
year one was going to be the hardest
because you have to go through
everything
once right and the second time is going
to be that much either the third time's
going to be that much easier
the first time i had to take the subway
the first time i had to go to the bagel
store we used to go to the first time i
had to walk into that apartment
first time i had to go back to work
first time i'd go on a date again
i remember making a list i wrote down a
list of all the firsts that i had to do
this year and i have it in my diary no i
had no idea you did that
because i knew i wanted to kind of check
them i'm like okay i can do this like
i have no choice i'm gonna have to do
these things
that's sort of genius to make a list
because the whole concept of dealing
with life after tragedy
is overwhelming
it's kind of genius to write it all down
all the things you're gonna have to do
that you don't want to do
and you only have to conquer each one
once so you don't have to do them all at
once
to make it a checklist it's actually
manifesting eating an elephant one
mouthful at a time
what did you learn about yourself
from this 20 years is such a long time
and i
beat myself up a lot for still being sad
you know i'm like 20 years should i be
over it you know
and yet i question like why do i
struggle
to feel sad and have a hard time talking
about it
and the weird way the world works i was
on instagram
two days ago flipping through and a ted
talk popped up
this woman nora mchenry
and she writes books on grief she had
lost her husband and she
had this one line that just stood out to
me and it said
you can move forward but you never move
on
and i think that gave me permission
after all these years to know
my life has moved forward yes i found
love
and yes i remarried and yes i have kids
and
yes i am so grateful and i'm happy and i
laugh and i'm funny and i can be all
these things and
yes i also cry and yes i'm still sad and
you don't move on you don't move on from
that it's not a thing you move on from
it wasn't a moment
it was my life it is my life
and i think i had to understand that
that it's it wasn't a moment
but you don't just get over it but you
can move forward
sort of accepting tragedy as part of our
journey and part of our life story
as much as anything else you know it's
formative right
i even remember somebody from peter's
family after the tragedy happened
said to my face don't worry you're young
you'll be fine and at the time i was so
angry
i was like how dare you tell me that i
couldn't understand that
in their minds i'm 25 and
looking back now there's a difference
between moving forward and
moving on one of the things that
happened for me is
i don't even know if you know this but
you gave me courage to do difficult
things
i'm not 100 sure that i would be where i
am in my career if it weren't for you
you know i had a job i worked for a big
ad agency when this happened
and as you healed
as you move forward i remember just
being in awe of your courage your
courage to go
through that list to pick up your life
and put it back together again
and that would always be my point of
reference like when i had difficult
decisions to make
at work i would be like if sarah can do
this i can do anything
and i remember i stopped being afraid of
difficult things even in relationships
because i saw the courage that you
exhibited
i don't have your courage
and i've never said this to you
i've said it to friends
i'm not sure i would have made it
through as healthy if you
as you have
it was easier to be the brother i mean i
think
you can never prepare yourself for these
things i even think back to myself like
how did i do this at the age of 25
how did i get through it there's no rule
book
and i just remember the first day the
thing that i was terrified about was
getting sucked into
a depression like that was my fear and i
just remember saying to myself
wake up every day get dressed put makeup
on
and go for a walk and i did it
every day and i i don't know where that
comes from and
brad and i my husband and i were talking
about this recently that
when kovit hit and we were all in
isolation and i did the same
thing i woke up every day i got dressed
put makeup on and went for a walk and i
think the only difference for me
this time during a tragedy in our world
was i wasn't alone
and it felt really nice that i would
look at other people on a walk and know
we're all thinking the same thing
i think the hardest part when that
happened for me was i was so alone
being so young and going through
something that no one could understand
and i hated being different i hated
people feeling sorry for me
i hated people giving me sympathy
because all i really wanted was what you
gave me which was just like
you gave me courage because you just
listened to me and you just were real
with me and i you need real
you don't need sympathy when you're
going through i mean for me
you know and the reason that i think you
and i got so close
during that time because i felt i could
just be me with you
i didn't have to pretend to be someone
else i didn't have to
try to be brave or
try to pretend i was okay you gave me
permission to just be and you were one
of the only people i think i was able to
be
with and just be
because everyone else just
looked at me differently and treated me
differently
you and i had a conversation after
september 11th
and it was a few weeks after the shock
had subsided
living in new york city after september
11th everybody had one degree of
separation everybody knew at least one
person who knew somebody who lost
somebody
everybody and remember you said you
would walk around the streets
and for the first time you didn't feel
alone
i totally remember that feeling because
it was exactly a year later
after peter died and i remember just
feeling like
wow there's a bigger club than just me
as a member here and even though i don't
know anybody
affected it didn't matter it speaks
a lot to how human beings exist as
social animals as tribal animals
where just simply knowing that the world
becomes your
support group just simply knowing that
other people
know what it's like to lose somebody
in a tragic accident that you went to
work in the morning thinking everything
was fine and then there was nobody came
home
just knowing that is cathartic
it's a strange thing that that would
offer catharsis just simply knowing that
people can relate
it goes to what you're saying which is i
didn't want to be different
and yet it's a sadly small club
sadly it's a bigger club now with covid
i think there's a strange understanding
that you have
an empathy i think it's about empathy
you just know
when you've been dealt a card that you
weren't expecting or asking for
and
it's not a club you want to be part of
but if you're there
unfortunately you have to get it in
order to know how to
see other people in that way
one of the things that it did for me and
again i don't even think these are
things that you and i have talked about
ever
it put things in remarkable perspective
obviously
you recognize how stupid most of the
things we do are
and how seriously we take these stupid
things when there are things that are
just way more important in the world
like relationships and family and love
and i remember my office was fantastic
they said take off as much time as you
needed to be there with your family and
i think i did i took off
at least two weeks i think because i was
just shuttling between
mommy and daddy's house where you were
and going home
i remember when i finally came back to
work i went to my boss
i said this in the most polite way i
could muster but i need to make a deal
with you
it's not really negotiable which is
if i get a phone call from sarah i don't
care what i'm doing i don't care what
meeting i'm in
i'm going to get up and walk out and if
she needs me to be with her i'm just
going to leave the office
i said it may never happen it may only
happen once i don't know
but i just need you to know that my
responsibility
number one is not here and they said
fine
and i think it happened twice i was in a
meeting you called you needed me and i
just got up and walked out and left the
office
no i didn't announce anything i just
left but again
it comes to courage which i'm not sure i
would have had even the courage to say
that to my boss in a nice way
if i didn't see the way that you were
able to manage through this
it's just one of those little things
that stands out that i remember
and helps me keep perspective of the
important things in life
have you been able to maintain that
sense of perspective
20 years on now yes i think that
where i've grown and learned from that
is that i don't
underestimate anyone else's sadness or
situations
i don't belittle and make my my problems
are bigger than anyone else's problems
but what i am able to do is make myself
have empathy i really do hear people and
say like that must be hard for them
right now
and i've become a much better listener
i really have i mean i was 25 years old
god i didn't know
i was partying and clubbing and getting
married and
my life took a big turn and i i had to
learn a lot of these like coping skills
the hard way and i'm grateful
in a way i'm grateful that i i learn
these things because they've helped me
in life
i'm grateful that i'm a better listener
and i'm grateful that i'm
more empathetic i'm grateful that i
think before i act
that's something i think my biggest
takeaway in life is
i think when i see that traffic light
changing
from green to orange i think is it worth
it
is it worth going i'm like no is it
worth running across the street
in new york city when it's you have you
know the ticker is counting down you
have three seconds to get across the
street
and i don't do it i would have at 25
but i don't do it i just think i'll just
wait till the next one
how has this helped you as a mother
in a way it's helped me in a way it's
hurt me
because i worry about the safety of my
kids and my husband
and you i worry about people around me
because i'm scared
of how easy it is to lose somebody that
you love
so i definitely had to help myself be
less overprotective and less worrying
more awesome
about all of you every time you go on a
plane every time you
travel i worry
but the good thing is it's made me
value family
so much i mean we're so close our family
you and i
and i wouldn't trade that for anything
are your kids learning to cope with
stress because of what you've learned
i mean my kids they're young i've never
they don't know the story i hope one day
i think about it all the time how will i
tell
them and what can they learn from it my
kids are pretty resilient and i think
that's probably from me i think you and
i
grew up in a resilient household as you
said we traveled a lot we had to start
new schools
we had each other i think my kids are
very similar
i really do i see a lot of what we had
in them
they lean on each other we just moved
across the country last year and
they embraced the change they were
amazing
i'm proud of them for that they do what
we did
i love them asking you permission to
have a sleepover and i remember the
first time i heard i'm like you're
letting them
go sleepovers like no no they sleepovers
in each other's rooms we used to do that
i love that they're close
how does it feel to talk about it now it
feels
cathartic in the way because i'm doing
it not for me
i'm doing it for somebody else and i
think that's
why i can do it i think i never wanted
to talk about it because i never wanted
to make it about me
but if i can do it with the hope that
someone else
can feel heard feel supported
feel hope that's why i can do this right
now
any advice you would give to your 20
year old self on how to move forward
what you've known now looking back that
you wish you knew then
it's hard to tell a 20 year old self to
appreciate
the little things because that's what
you love about your 20s is that you just
don't think you just do and you just
live
but i think for for my 20 year old self
i feel i just have immense gratefulness
like for my experiences the good things
and the bad things
and i had amazing highs and
an amazing low but
i would tell myself hold on to those
moments because
they shape you they shape who you're
going to be in 20 years
the good and the bad it's really
accepting the journey right
as opposed to trying to reject or
hide or as you said move on from
why would you right like these things
they help us learn things they help us
grow there's so much positive that came
out of this as well
they're just not moments in time and i
think that's what i would tell my 20
year old self
they're not just moments in time they
are experiences
that are you that become you and i just
don't think you
have that perspective in your 20s you
know everything's just
a thing a moment a day an event
it's larger than that and one day we'll
look back at this time in
life and think the same
there was a movie i don't know if you
remember that movie with gwyneth paltrow
sliding doors sure i think about that
movie all the time because that was
basically my life
it was actually on a train like she
walked into one door and her life went
one way and
if she walked into a different door 30
seconds later her life would be
completely different
and i think about that movie because
that is life
you can't control what door you're going
to go through and what's going to happen
but
you just have to accept and hope you
made the right decision
you know i think to myself what if i
waited for the next train what if we
took the different door
you know but that's not life life is a
sliding door
that's also what makes it exciting it's
kind of a
motto of my life i think about that all
the time
what if i do this we'll have a different
outcome maybe
that's okay i'm gonna turn off the mics
now and give you a hug
thank you for doing this thank you for
being here for me always
always
[Music]
this was the final episode of the first
season of a bit of optimism
i encourage you to go back and listen to
the ones you haven't heard yet
or forward the ones to your friends you
think will inspire them
we'll be back very soon but until then
take care of yourself and take care of
each other
[Music]